Digamos que queremos averiguar cuánto es 8 ÷
0.4. Pausa este video y trata de resolverlo
por tu cuenta antes de que lo hagamos juntos.
Muy bien. Ahora, una forma de abordar esto
es pensar todo en términos de décimas, y te
puedes preguntar ¿por qué en décimas? Bueno,
acabo de describir el segundo número como
cuatro décimas, entonces ¿a cuánto equivale
8 en términos de décimas? Bueno, sabemos que 1
entero = 10 décimas, por lo que 8 enteros = 80
décimas. Entonces puedo escribir esto: en lugar
de 8, puedo escribirlo como 80 décimas, que vamos
a dividir entre 4 décimas. Entonces, si tengo 80
de algo y lo divido en grupos de 4 de ese algo,
¿cuántos grupos iguales voy a tener? Bueno, voy a
tener 80 dividido en cuatro grupos, u 80 dividido
entre 4 -permíteme escribir esto-. Esto va a ser
igual a 80 / 4, u 80 ÷ 4, y 8 ÷ 4 es 2, por lo que
80 ÷ 4 va a ser igual a 20, así que 8 ÷ 0.4 = 20.
Otra forma de pensar en esto es reescribir 8 ÷ 0.4
como 8 / 0.4, y luego, si quisiera reescribir
esto, podría decir "Oye, ¿puedo multiplicar el
numerador y el denominador por alguna cantidad
que elimine el decimal del denominador?" Bueno,
puedo multiplicar el denominador por 10, y si no
quiero cambiar el valor de la fracción, tengo que
multiplicar el numerador por esa misma cantidad.
Bueno, ¿qué nos da esto? Esto va a ser igual a,
en el denominador de aquí sólo voy a tener un
4 porque nos deshicimos del decimal, y en el
numerador voy a tener 80, entonces, una vez más
obtenemos 80 / 4 = 20. Hagamos otro ejemplo, pero
en este caso trataremos con centésimas. Entonces,
digamos que queremos averiguar cuánto es 48 ÷
0.24 o 24 centésimas. Pausa este video y trata de
resolverlo. Aquí podemos hacer algo muy similar,
esta vez estamos tratando con centésimas, por lo
que podríamos intentar expresar todo en términos
de centésimas, entonces: 48 es igual a ¿cuántas
centésimas? Bueno, sabemos que 1 = 100 centésimas,
por lo que 48 será igual a 48 x 100 centésimas.
Tal vez lo escriba así, o tal vez pueda decir:
"Oye, eso es 4800 centésimas", así que,
de hecho, lo escribiré de esa manera:
esto será 4800 centésimas dividido entre
-esto es 24 centésimas- 24 centésimas,
y ¿a qué va a ser igual esto? Bueno, la misma
lógica que usamos aquí: si tengo 4800 de algo y lo
divido en grupos iguales de 24 de ese algo, bueno
voy a tener 4800 dividido en 24 grupos iguales,
podríamos expresar 4800 como 48 x 100, así que
esto es igual a 48 x 100 / 24, y, por supuesto,
podrías ver esto como 48 / 24. Y muchos de
ustedes ya lo habrán hecho en su cabeza,
multiplicado por 100: ¿a qué es igual 48 / 24?
Bueno, eso va a ser igual a 2, 2 x 100 = 200,
por lo que esto de aquí es igual a 200.
También puedes hacerlo de forma similar a
como lo resolvimos aquí arriba, donde en lugar
de expresarlo con palabras, lo puedes expresar
como 48 ÷ 0.24, y en lugar de multiplicar
el numerador y el denominador por 10 tal vez
quieras multiplicarlo por otra cosa para obtener
números enteros, tanto en el numerador como en
el denominador. Piensa en esto después de este
video e intenta resolverlo de esa manera también.